- [Instructor] In this
video, we're gonna talk
about something called
determinants of matrices.
So I'll start just
telling you the notation
and how do you compute it.
And then we'll think about
ways that you can interpret it.
So let's give ourselves
a two by two matrix here.
So, and actually, I'll
give it in general terms.
So let's say that this
top-left term here is A,
and then this one here is B the top-right.
The bottom-left is C,
and then let's call this bottom-right D.
And I'm gonna do that
in a different color.
So this is D right over here.
the determinant of this matrix.
And actually, let me
just call this matrix.
Let's say that this is matrix A.
So there's a bunch of ways
to call the determinant,
or have the notation for the determinant.
We could write it like this.
We could have these little,
it looks like absolute value signs,
but it really means determinant
when you apply it to a matrix.
So the determinant of matrix A.
You can write it that way.
You could write it this way,
the determinant of matrix A.
You could write it that way.
Or you could write it this way,
where you put these lines that look
like big absolute value
signs instead of the brackets
when you describe the numbers.
So you could also write it this way.
And I haven't explained
what determinant is
or even how to compute it yet.
I'm just talking about the notation
of how you even talk about
the determinant of a matrix.
So you can also write it this way,
just rewrite the whole matrix
with those vertical bars next to it.
This is defined as,
and we'll see how it's
useful in the future,
the top-left time's the bottom-right.
So A times D minus
the top-right times the bottom-left.
BC.
So another way to think about it,
it is just these two, the
product of these two minus,
so that's those two right over there,
minus the product of
these two right over here.
So let's just first, before
we start to interpret this,
get a little practice, just
computing a determinant.
So let me give you a matrix.
So let's say I have the matrix one,
negative two, three, and five.
Pause this video and
see if you can compute
the determinant of this matrix.
Let's call this matrix B.
I want you to figure out
the determinant of matrix B.
What is this going to be equal to?
All right, now let's do this together.
So you're going to have the
product of these two numbers.
So we have one times five
minus
the product of these two numbers,
which is three times negative two.
And that of course, is going to be equal
to one times five is five,
three times negative two is negative six.
But we're subtracting a negative six.
Five minus negative six is the
same thing as five plus six
which is going to be equal to 11.
Now that we know how to
compute a determinant,
in a future video,
I will give you an
interesting interpretation
of the determinant.